Quand je me présenterai à la présidence 2024, nous
saurions certainement que je me
moque d'elle. Quand je me présenterai à la présidence
2024, nous aurions créé tellement d'emplois
que je suis derrière la course, je marche Kanye
West, je l'aime maintenant, peut-être dans quelques  des années,
je devrai me présenter contre lui, je ne
sais pas donc je vais retirer ça mais tu sais pourquoi
il a été si gentil avec moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] nous nous sommes rencontrés
et nous  a commencé à travailler ensemble,
finalement, il travaillait sur sa démo au
moment où je travaillais aussi sur la mienne
et je chantais des refrains pour sa démo, il
me donnait des rythmes pour ma démo, tu sais
ce qui s'est passé pour une raison,
Dieu savait que j'avais un message pour toi  je sais que j'avais
une mission mais il savait que personne ne s'en souciait, il a
dit Connie, je vais faire en sorte que
quelqu'un se soucie de toi BAM, j'ai failli
mourir, c'est l'une des meilleures choses qui
puisse arriver à un rappeur [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous essayons de mettre en place
des cours de production musicale dans les lycées donc au lieu d'
aller au lycée et ils vous disent
de refuser ce CD de Snoop Dogg et si
vous aviez un cours où ils  je t'ai dit de
monter le volume comme si j'étais allé à l'école d'
art musical et de basket-ball et que je suis resté assis pendant
l'autre bien sûr, tu sais que
j'ai eu mes notes mais ce sont ces choses
qui ont rendu ça amusant qui m'ont inspiré à me
lever le matin  comme si c'était la meilleure
année de ma vie, je voulais que ces gens
essaient de faire de la bonne musique et
[Musique]
je pensais que c'était très irrespectueux,
c'est un grand musicien mais en tant que
personne, il n'est pas comme un modèle ou
quoi que ce soit et je  je pense que non seulement ses
fans sont déçus mais que sa mère serait
déçue
[Musique] [
Musique]
c'est notre président, il doit être le
plus frais les playas les avions les plus volants
les meilleures usines et nous devons faire en sorte que notre
noyau soit au pouvoir nous avons  pour créer
des emplois en Amérique parce que notre meilleure
exportation est constituée d'idées de divertissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous